they're offering me 25 million dollars  to find him and kill him  god help me it was the largest attack on  arkham asylum they've seen yet  and that i'm your pre  it started the world's largest manhunt  and detective james gordon was the right  man for the job  from the same team that brought you  batman their dark designs a cat and  mouse story where nothing is quite what  it seems  they want everyone to think it was me  little me  this won't be my last  [Music]  time it's different what gordon finds  and what the joker wants him to see will  change everything  you haven't found the case yet have you  found the case yet  [Music]  and they don't even know it the joke is  on you  wow  jimbo  i didn't do it  you